y es que a partir de hoy primero de
octubre venezuela tiene un nuevo cono
monetario se trata de la tercera
reconversión en 13 años la
hiperinflación y la dificultad de las
transacciones administrativas y también
las bancarias en ese país empujaron así
al gobierno de nicolás maduro a tomar la
medida de quitarle seis ceros a la
moneda con el bolívar digital el
gobierno espera impulsar aún más las
transacciones virtuales además de
permitir a los venezolanos que tengan
dinero en efectivo en sus manos para
ello yo le quiero dar la bienvenida a
aaron no olmos él es economista de la
universidad central de venezuela
especialista en finanzas de empresas
también de esta universidad y también
docente e investigador gracias a sharon
por estar aquí con nosotros en directo
américa en france24 le quiero pedir que
nos explique un poco cómo funciona este
nuevo cono monetario pero además en una
economía completamente dolarizada qué va
a pasar con el dólar que digamos que es
la moneda que más circula en venezuela-
explicarnos un poco la audiencia
internacional qué está pasando con la
economía venezolana que es difícil de
entender ciertamente
sí buenos días gracias por la invitación
no efectivamente a partir de hoy entra
en vigencia el bolívar bolívar de
digital como se ha denominado según el
comunicado publicado el 6 de agosto del
banco central de venezuela
son 60 que nos sumaría en 14 las 3
reconversión es que ha vivido el país en
esto supone que es sistema financiero el
día de hoy está precisamente un proceso
de la ecuación de las plataformas para
que todas las expresiones moneda en el
país estén dividida entre un millón la
situación de hiperinflación en venezuela
40 más de 45 meses continuas y
precisamente pues el ejecutivo asume
esta decisión en el marco de tratar de
los posibles
atenuar el efecto de
incremento de precios pero cuando la
previa van en 35 de bolívar y el avance
del precio del dólar a ser pues que la
medida por sí sola pues vaya a corregir
algún problema estructural no esto es
una economía multi moneda donde
principalmente el dólar es la moneda de
mayor uso y habría que decir que no
necesariamente la entrada en vigencia de
este proceso de reconversión en trasero
que vive venezuela va a desalentar a
desincentivar a los venezolanos que ya
tiene una economía montada sobre el
dólar y otras divisas para buscar ahora
una nueva moneda o 60 - aaron le
pregunto si ya son tres las conversiones
monetarias cuál es la diferencia de esta
que busca el gobierno de nicolás maduro
con hacer esta reconversión añitos de
agua fría un poco
bueno mira la diferencia que hay de esta
tercera reconversión con las anteriores
es que bueno en las anteriores no
estábamos en hiperinflación en las
anteriores éste no había pandemias en
las anteriores este precio del petróleo
y la producción petrolera no se
encontraban en los niveles en los que se
encuentran realmente venezuela toda una
situación muy compleja sí y lo cierto es
que una medida de este estilo por sí
sola no solventan los problemas
estructurales como ya dije no entonces
esta vez sí a partir de ahora de primero
de octubre además de tener este nuevo
bolívar
si bien se hace llamar digital no
necesariamente
nos hacen ver a través de las recetas
oficiales este sentido que bueno vamos a
tener un amor monetario habría que ver
si van a venir algunas medidas
adicionales no porque por sí solas como
primero acabas de decir simplemente
sería un pañito de agua caliente para
tratar de solventar un problema muy
estructura muy grande que tiene muchos
años ocurriendo y que efectivamente no
se solventa sólo con cambiar cantidad de
ceros sino que hay que recibir el
aparato productivo hay que gobernar
protagonismo sector empresarial e
industrial y eso pareciera que no está
en la agenda por lo tanto ni un momento
aaron como toman esto los venezolanos
que se dice en las calles de venezuela
además es más complicado cierto para la
gente del común tener un nuevo cono
monetario en venezuela era necesario
realmente
mira en principio el tema de la
reconversión era necesaria para atacar
el problema al sobre el flujo el flow a
nivel de las operaciones de los sistemas
administrativos y grandes empresas el
venezolano común en la calles y
finalmente está la expectativa de ver
cuál va a ser el efecto que va a tener
esto sobre su día a día ya salario
mínimo se debe una cantidad ínfima
pasaría de siete a siete bolívares
después de la tela de la reconversión el
tipo de cambio entidad ya se ubicaba
este un dólar cinco millones de
bolívares más de cinco millones y por
cierto bueno nada de esto de alguna
manera le está dando más poder de compra
al venezolano máxime cuando por
respuesta en kobe recientemente
publicada el día martes de esta semana
en las gracias católicas de fallos por
ejemplo se nos recordaba pues el 94 por
ciento de pobreza
generalizada y el 79% pobreza extrema
que hay en el país no entonces esta
medida no necesariamente se solventa a
esos problemas no necesariamente vamos a
ver una elevación después de comprar el
venezolano y básicamente la economía va
a seguir girando en torno a monedas
extranjeras porque hasta ahora no se ha
hecho nada para devolverle valor real al
bolívar ahora me su opinión le quiero
preguntar que se tiene que hacer
realmente una o dos medidas efectivas
para poder frenar la hiperinflación que
vive venezuela además como usted lo dijo
el estudio de la universidad católica
andrés bello en venezuela nueve de cada
diez personas viven en un umbral de
pobreza extrema y además preocupante
es así así para batir la hiperinflación
lo que hay que hacer es medidas
económicas coordinadas se llama
coordinación macroeconómica eso está
dispuesto en el 320 constitucional y
básicamente es el uso armonizado de la
política monetaria fiscal comercial
cambiaria y bueno en el caso nuestro
sería básicamente pues permitirle al
sector productivo del sector industrial
en venezuela primero volver a producir a
generar bienes y servicios en el mercado
interno para abastecer este mercado con
bienes y servicios nacionales pero
evidentemente también necesitaríamos que
el encaje legal se modificará para que
banco central permitiera que el sistema
financiero volviera con su actividad es
crear ámbitos importantes para dinamizar
la actividad económica del país y en
cosa de unos pocos años porque el
problema que tenemos en varios órganos
pues va a solventar en dos días pero
haciendo política económica consistente
orientada al hecho productivo es posible
que comencemos a ver una recuperación de
los signos y de los principales
indicadores de crecimiento del país
aaron rápidamente la pregunta con usted
hablaba de las posibles salidas pero en
cuánto tiempo cuánto tiempo va a tomar
que la economía venezolana medianamente
se regularice
bueno fíjate tú que el economista
pregunta eso siempre no siempre se
mantiene una bola de cristal porque la
recuperación económica de los países
tienen que ver con una dinámica bastante
compleja de toma de decisiones y
evidentemente tienen un aparato
productivo que está largamente afectado
y eso no se va a recuperar en cosa de
semanas pero si comienza pasa bien las
cosas en el entendido que siempre buen
momento para hacer bien las cosas y se
hace política de estado más 9 gobierno
es independientemente desde el grupo
se sigue haciendo lo mismo siempre bueno
pues en cosa de tres años comenzaríamos
a ver cambios porque hay que recordar si
el pib en ese plano sigue contrayéndose
tiene siete años en caída libre y eso no
se puede recuperar de la noche de la
mañana y necesitamos recuperar la
confianza de las instituciones no
solamente las instituciones nacionales
sino que las instituciones del resto del
mundo vuelvan a confiar en venezuela y
eso no se va a lograr si no se da un
mensaje firme y fuerte de cambio de
política económica y ojalá sea pronto
aaron gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa en france 24 que te
guste sufrir gesto día